après un succès aux états unis la voici
dans son pays natal
camille bordas est venu dédicacer son
troisième roman isidore et les autres à
la librairie du furet du nord de skywest
je crois que les libraires ont beaucoup
aimé le livre donc ça c'est toujours
c'est toujours hyper gratifiant
là j'ai fait quelques rencontres en
librairie à paris je vais à montpellier
arles à nantes donc c'est super quoi
c'est le roman traduit de l'anglais par
l'auteure elle-même est un véritable
coup de coeur des libraires qui avait
envie de le partager avec les lecteurs
on avait envie de montrer que on est
libraire et que ce magasin a du
potentiel et qu'on avait envie de le
faire vivre au maximum
l'occasion de créer des rencontres
inattendues c'est honteux et un cadeau
pour notre future fille qui donc par
colissimo coïncidence extraordinaire
voilà ça avait l'air amusant et dans la
même veine que l'attrape-coeurs qui est
un mélange préférez donc c'est pour ça
aussi que ça malgré un petit peu attirés
en abordant le thème de l'adolescence
isidore et les autres est souvent
comparé au célèbre roman de salinger
camille bordas aime écrire en toute
simplicité pour toucher directement le
lecteur une méthode qui fait ses preuves
j'aime beaucoup en ce moment c'est un
beau livre vous le conseille après sa
tournée française l'auteur devrait se
rendre en italie où le livre pas être
traduit tout en gardant dans un coin de
sa tête ses idées pour son quatrième
roman